اليوتيوب حسن سليمان ابو فيلا صديق
نفتفعلكم هو من المؤثرين قولا وفعلا
ودائما بيسال تسخير شهره في عمل الخير
السنه الماضيه مثل هذه الايام شارك في
النسخه الثانيه من فعاليات اجمل شتاء في
العالم وشارك في لنجعل شتائهم ادفى واللي
فيها قدر يجمع 11 مليون دولار في 12 يوم
ودخل موسوعه جينيس بعد ما فضل في غرفه
زجاجيه وفاتح بث مباشر الى ان جمع المبلغ
السنه هذه ابو فله مشارك في مسابقه كنوز
اجمل شتاء واللي بتيجي من ضمن فعاليات
اجمل شتاء في العالم
وهذه المسابقه بتعتبر اكبر مسابقه سياحيه
من نوع وبتقدر قيمه جوائز منها مليون درهم
ورح تكون موزعه ضمن 51 كنز في مختلف مناطق
دبي السياحيه وكل احد موجود في الامارات
يقدر يشارك في هذه المسابقه والهدف منها
غير اجوائز الماديه هو ابراز طبعا اهم من
وجهه السياحيه والترفيه في الامارات
بثقافتها وتاريخها وتراثها
وامس السبت انطلق البث المباشر لابو فله
من حسابه الشخصي على يوتيوب ومتواجد في
القريه العالميه في دبي ورح يفضل البث
شغال الى ان يتم العثور على 51 كنز وابو
فله ضمن البث راح يعرض فيديوهات ودللات
بتساعد المشاركين في المسابقه للعثور على
اماكن الصناديق او الكنوز طبعا المبالغ
اللي في الصناديق مختلفه من واحد لاخر
والتحدي الاكبر هو الوصول للكنز اللي فيه
500,000 درهم ومن بعد ما يتم العثور على
الكنز بيتوجه حامل الصندوق القريه
العالميه لتم فتحه واعطاء الكنز اللي فاز
في خلي ينضم لنا اليوتيوب
يا مرحبتين يا هلا عرفنا على زميلك الي
معك كمان
يا يوسف ابو فله السنه الماضيه يعني كانت
شغلانه اجلسنا نتابع العداد والفلوس
بتتجمع السنه كيف الوضع انت بدات امس
فعليه صحيح
او جده
تقريبا هي الفكره بكل بساطه قاعدين لمده
60 ساعه 51 جائزه متنوعه من من اصغر جائزه
لين النصف مليون درهم حاليا تقريبا مر
تقريبا يوم وربع نصف الجواز راحت او اكثر
من نصف الجواز اتوقع بكره راح يلعب الحمد
لله وقاعد الفكره بكل بساطه قاعد تسوي شيء
ترفيه انت جرحتي كل شيء خساره الفكره بكل
شيء قاعد يسوي قاعد يسوي شيء ترفيه جميل
ممتع مع الناس
اللي ما بيشوفوا البث وان شاء الله
هيشوفوا البث بعد هذه المقابله للي ما
بيشوفوا البث اشرح لي مثلا
قصه من القصص اللي صارت احد من اللي فازوا
جميل احد من اللي فاز بكل بساطه اللي قاعد
يسوي هنا 51 جائزه منتشره في جميع
الامارات اللي قاعد يسوي فاتحين البث اللي
عليه المشاهد يسويه من انه يتابعون واللي
عايشه في الامارات وايضا خارج الامارات في
جوائز اللي خارج الامارات
الداخله الامارات اللي يسوونه اللي
يتابعون البث يشوفون الادله اللي قاعد من
عرضها في البث ويروحون ويروحون الاماكن
السياحيه اماكن تكون جميله واحنا نعرف في
اجمل شيء اجمل الشتاء يروح اماكن السياحيه
ويروح للاماكن الجميله ويشوف التعليمات
بالضبط
51 صندوق
حاليا حاليا
اوك مثلا في دليل حتى مثلا ان يكون او في
العين مثلا يكون فوق جبل حفيد مثلا وانه
يكون مثلا فوق جبل حفيد في البوابه او في
الدخله وهكذا التعليمات تكون رؤوس اغنام
ان مثلا او في مثلا احلى وحده قالت مثلا
تروح للبايك دي اكس في بايك وتروح لتوصل
للسد لا تدخل بالنفق او التغريبا همم
وبعدين بتلاقي الصندوق في اناره مكتوب
عليها 488 فهذه تقريبا 20 سياره الى 30
سياره وقفت في الميدان وصارت زحمه الى
القصه
احد بيروح في نفس الوقت يعني
نعم نعم هذه المتعه ان عباره عن تنافس
جميل جدا
وانه يسوون تجربه يعني في منهم اللي سواه
جديده وفي منهم اللي متعودين فيها في
التجربه هذه في كثير من الفايزين اصلا
اغلب الفايزين يعرفون الاماكن اول ما يشوف
انه المكان
انا قدامي في البث المباشر انت طالع عادي
بس رجعت الان اوكي صوره ارجع تتحركت همم
بس عشان كمان الناس اللي بيتابعونا الان
نحنا بنبس على شاشه العربيه وجاسين بنبص
عبر حسابك كمان الخاص المقابله شايفه
صورتي منور في في البث ههه
اه النص مليون الى الان اعلى ثلاث جوائز
الى الان نصف مليون و150000 وال 50,000
درهم الى الان ما حد جابها بس حاليا
تقريبا في 10 اشخاص الى الان ما جو عندهم
العشر صناديق راح يجون فرح يشوف اذا راح
يفوزون بالمبلغ وهو وهي حظ صناديق بتفرزها
بالكور وعن طريق الرقم نشوف شو راح يطلع
لك طيب انت شخصيا عارف مثلا فين الاكبر
ثلاث جوائز هذه اه
جدا جميل والله والله العظيم اني ما اعرف
ولا شيء
[موسيقى]
مدير الامارات
يا عمو الاثنين فاضل يعني طيب ممتاز هذه
المعلومه اللي قلت لي اياها هلا انه رقم
مدير اعمالك عندنا فهنتواصل الان نخلي
رح نشوف فريق تفاعلكم رايح في التراجر
هانت معكم كمان بنبحث عن الجواب الله
يعطيك العافيه
ما شاء الله فلوس كثير جالس بتجيب ما شاء
الله
[ضحك]
جميعا الله يرزق الجميع